what don't they understand about hex
sure or crypto what do they understand
about you yeah so here's here's how the
hater pyramid goes
first you have people that think that uh
all crypto is a scam
no actually you've got people think
capitalism just came
you've got people who think the stock
market's a scam right and i just did a
lot i just did an interview with uh the
wolf of wall street yeah jordan buffer
yeah
and then you got people who scammed
everyone in the stock market let's just
be real here for a second convicted so i
don't know what kind of credibility he
has not regarding you but just no for
sure in the stock market so yeah he he
knows how scams in the stock market work
because he ran one of the biggest ones
um so then we've got okay capitalism
scam stock market scam crypto is a scam
yeah
all of krypto is a scam except bitcoin
all of cryptoscam except bitcoin
ethereum all of crypto scam accept
whatever you bought yeah right and then
you just have this like
you know hater list of like and then i
look at these things as tools right so
when i go to my toolbox i'm not like
phillips head's a scam i'm only a torx
head maximalist no like they have
different parameters yeah people don't
realize that the phillips head was
actually designed to strip out like so
it's you know meant to not
i'm not going to get into the wood shop
work of it but like yeah let's not lose
our listeners by getting into the wood
guys buckle up your seat belts and put
on your hard hat tool shop time tim the
tool man taylor richard hart in the
house i just installed two bidets from
my mom last week
we saw that congratulations hopefully
everything's clean in that house you
could you could watch me install a bidet
in 30 minutes from start to finish
anyway the the the crypto hater works
right so
what i
people people are so damn stupid i gotta
educate everybody so first
ponzi scheme okay a ponzi scheme
collapses because it owes people money
that it can't pay it promises returns
that it doesn't generate actual profit
to pay and therefore to make up for the
lack of profit they steal from the
investments of other people the early
the the newest people yeah to pay the
oldest people bernie madoff and then it
collapsed bernie madoff act like and so
what are the parameters by which you
know you're dealing with a ponzi
one the original sin the fraud the lie
there is a lie they say there's a
business activity that is profitable and
that you will share in that profit and
in reality there is not a profitable
activity and you will only get your
money stolen to pay somebody else
and notice there's huge counterparty
risk there's a guy in charge there's a
dude in charge
so
the securities exchange commission
exists to prevent this particular form
of fraud doesn't always succeed bernie
madoff was licensed and regulated
and he ran the goddamn nasdaq
he was the chairman of the board of the
nasdaq yes
and talk about like what's it called the
the the sheep in the uh i'm sorry the
wolf in the relationship the wolf and
the sheep's uh wolf and sheep's clothing
yeah that whole thing so
enron was a scam fairness was a scam
bernie madoff i don't remember what his
thing was called that was a scam
you know just getting uh
disclosures
from an entity and and being licensed to
trade doesn't mean what you're doing
isn't a bad idea or a scam
so
you have a ponzi if there's the original
sin of deceit
and
there's a middleman
that stops paying you
now let's take hex who's the middleman
there isn't one there's just you you
meant your own coins just like a bitcoin
miner no one gives them to you no one
holds them when you lock your coins up
you destroy them when your stake is
ended you mint new coins and you met
your rewards so even the contract itself
doesn't do custody
so you run your own code you're the only
person in the world that can pay your
own returns no one can stop you from
doing it it's sufficient sufficiently
decentralized at launch
unlike ethereum ethereum launched
ethereum had a crowdsale people turned
their bitcoin into ethereum and then
eventually they built it
uh you know bitcoin they're working on
it all the time hex is totally finished
and complete and uneditable and
unchangeable it's the least security
like of anything it's the least
counterparty risk it's the maximum 100
uptime we've had flawless perfect
operation with 100 uptime google hasn't
google was down last week for 30 minutes
globally microsoft hasn't they were down
globally a couple months ago hex has
never been down bitcoin.org had a scam
on their homepage
twice i think
hex dominates all these things but for
some people for some reason people are
just immune to reality you're like guys
we're killing you well let me ask you
then so fair to say with that actually i
beat the ponzi one exactly but we didn't
do we didn't do pyramid or uh bubble yet
which i'm ready next but the the answer
is that it's neither of those is what i
assume right real cryptocurrencies
eliminate counterparty risk and
eliminate middlemen so here's my
question a lot of fake ones because
there's a lot of people i want to get to
like the emotions like when people say
that about you
and you're not a con artist and you're
not a scam artist and you're not a ponzi
schemer how does that make you feel as a
legitimate businessman well it makes me
very angry because i'm here it when they
when they slander me and libel me it
makes it harder for me to change the
world in a positive way
because
basically there's a ten to one ratio of
it takes ten units of effort to fight
lies and takes one unit of effort to
generate them and therefore the
asymmetry
makes it a lot harder to to educate
these people
so like i'd rather take people i would
rather take people calling me a scammer
than no news about me at all because
some portion of those people will do
their research and learn you know the
famous quote by roger stone there's no
such thing as bad news well that too but
he says i'd rather be infamous than
never famous at all right yeah you abide
by that yeah it's true if you want to
make a difference in the world so
take uh
so we've we've covered ponzi by the way
you know what you know what scammers
leave a trail of victims you know what
victims do they complain very loudly
yeah i've been doing this for 15 or 20
years not a single human being has ever
said i scam them
don't people who say that i'm a scammer
people have never worked with me never
participated in nothing i've done fair
point never bought my products never
used them like i had a car stereo store
people still running around beating them
trunks up with them like just it works
good everything i've ever done i've
given people a good deal great product
great service every single time so if
you like that clip click right here to
watch another or if you want to watch
the entire saucecast click right here
[Music]